et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir Georges Croze bonsoir
alors Georges vous êtes parti de rien
vous êtes monté au sommet de l'échelle
sociale parvenant à gagner jusqu'à
100000 euros par an mais au début des
années 90 la nouvelle politique
salariale de votre employeur divise
votre salaire par deux vous êtes alors
incapable de faire face aux dettes
contractées au temps des années fast
vous plongez dans la spirale infernale
du surendettement pour vous et votre
famille c'est la descente aux enfers
vous nous raconterez ça à 20h
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes né il y a 71 ans le 16 avril
1939 de parents d'origine hongroise mais
ayant contracté une tuberculose en
couche votre mère décède en janvier 1940
9 mois après ma naissance elle mouraï
voilà alors vous vous retrouvez dans la
région de Moulins dans l'Allier élevé
par une mère nourricière et la balle
instituteur vous accorde très peu
d'importance comme à tous les autres
enfants d'ailleurs de l'Assistance
publique vous êtes dispensés d'apprendre
vos leçons et l'instituteur vous demande
de vous occuper du poil à bois voilà
j'ai commencé mon démarrage
intellectuel en quelque sorte avec un
handicap
heureusement pour moi ben voilà il y a
un instituteur plus altruiste que les
autres qui arrivent et là vous devenez
l'un des meilleurs élèves de
l'établissement jusqu'à votre bac
mathématique en 1959 cela en dit long
quand même sur votre combativité vous
avez rattrapé le retard complètement en
un an voilà
alors ensuite vous entrez au PTT vous
vous mariez vous faites 24 mois en
Algérie et là vous rencontrez un
inspecteur d'assurance qui vous propose
de vendre vous aussi des assurances aux
particuliers alors au début vous gardez
votre boulot au PTT mais à un moment
vous finissez par ne plus faire que ça
oui comme j'étais déjà battant j'ai
voulu finalement gagner plus pour
permettre à mon épouse déjà de ne plus
travailler et donc d'assumer seul les
ressources du ménage vous étiez bon pour
ça vous aviez un talent pour vendre des
assurances aux gens mais comme vous avez
honte de vendre des produits financiers
de mauvaise qualité vous décidez
d'acheter un petit portefeuille
d'assurance de 50 clients à Besançon
voilà ça a commencé à aller bien dans la
foulée vous achetez un appartement et
vous faites un enfant
c'est une bonne époque ça commence à
bien marcher pour vous là
de toute façon je ne rentrais pas tant
que je n'avais pas récupéré disons trois
quatre contrats par jour
alors tout va bien jusqu'au jour vous
avez un accident de voiture sur
l'autoroute un carambolage géant du côté
de Fontainebleau vous restez six mois
sans travailler mais vous vous
rebondissez très vous en sortez vous
retrouvez un job encore plus passionnant
avec 50 agents sous vos ordres
là vous décidez de vous remettre à votre
compte avec un associé et vous détenez
bientôt le plus gros portefeuille de la
de la région je ne comptais pas mes
heures et c'était au détriment de la vie
de famille et ce n'est qu'après avoir
dépassé la quarantaine que pour échapper
au stress du boulot vous retournez
travailler dans une grande compagnie
d'assurance et bientôt vous retrouvez
avec 27 départements sous votre
responsabilité tout ça pour dire vous
êtes quand même un gros bosseur un
entrepreneur à l'époque vous gagnez
jusqu'à 100000 euros par an
et là vous êtes nommé en Aquitaine je
sais pas ce qui se passe vous montrer un
petit peu moins performant
et votre patron ne vous paye que la
partie fixe de votre salaire contenu de
la contreperformance il a décidé comme
ça sans négociation préalable de me
rendre au salaire de moitié mais par
contre j'ai l'intégralité de mes dettes
ouais dans votre taux d'entêtement qui
était de 25% bah comme vous gagnez deux
fois moins il passe à 50%. voilà et
sentir compte de l'impôt décalé que vous
voyez avec un en retard et qui tient
compte des années fastes alors voilà là
vous êtes obligés d'emprunter pour payer
vos impôts et vous emprunter à 21 % pour
Monsieur voyons le tapis rouge pas de
problème sous 24 heures j'obtenais
pratiquement ce que je voulais y compris
ma propre banque qui elle me dit si vous
avez besoin pas de problème je vous
augmente je propose à découvert
sans souci je pensais que ça allait être
que provisoire et que finalement les
prêts donc la connerie c'est que j'ai
fait déjà j'ai commencé mes deux pré
revolving à ce moment là voilà à 21% à
21 % pour payer dans la peau plutôt que
de solliciter auprès des impôts une
remise exceptionnelle compte tenu de la
chute de mes revenus alors là vous ne
dites rien à votre femme et à vos
enfants vous leur cachez la réalité de
la situation et comme ça marche pour
vous il se doute de rien en fait ils
vous font confiance
en revanche vous vous passez venu à
calculer vos échéances ma femme dort
tranquillement à côté de moi et moi je
je songe comment vais-je faire et j'ai
je ne peux pas lui avouer voilà je
manque de courage
alors là Cetelem Sofinco Cofinoga
Cofidis vous les avez tous vous avez 24
crédits pour un encours de 350 000 euros
à l'époque vous êtes foutus dans une
drôle de situation quand même
j'étais complètement acculé et ma propre
banque
supprime absolument
tous les découverts sont sans aucun
préavis pour l'instant je n'avais pas eu
un seul incident pendant 8 ans j'ai pu
cacher la chose pierre vous prenez des
crédits pour payer les crédits enfin je
veux dire
tout ça jusqu'au jour où vos créanciers
finissent par débrancher la perfusion et
là c'est le début de la descente aux
enfers c'est à dire qu'à la fin du mois
votre banquier prélève sur votre compte
la totalité là vous avez pu aucun revenu
donc voilà vous décidez enfin d'en
parler à votre fils d'abord à votre
femme ensuite en leur disant voilà ça
fait 8 ans que je vous laisse croire que
que tout va bien en fait je vous ai joué
un sale tour j'ai honte à c'est terrible
et je revois ça encore bon de toute
façon avec le temps maintenant je non je
n'en pleure plus mais de façon je suis
passé au-delà parce qu'il faut faire
preuve de beaucoup de d'abnégation
d'humilité de
cette atroce mais en fait par contre je
peux dire que j'ai acquis une victoire
immense c'est de voir que ma famille est
restée unie et que mon épouse m'a
vraiment pardonné spontanément et ça
doit être un sale moment
alors là les créanciers voir celles il
vous appelle au téléphone toutes les
heures chez l'employeur chez les voisins
est-ce qu'il a toujours sa boîteure vous
pouvez me donner le numéro
d'immatriculation je reçois des
télégrammes et maintenant des PTT
télégram qui sont lus et dont l'agent
députés dans un petit village des Landes
où nous habitions vous voyez donc on
m'avait vraiment sali au maximum mon
fils c'était le surendetté du coin
votre employeur vous pousse vers la
sortie et vous prenez une retraite
anticipée à l'âge de 60 ans voilà alors
là il y a un épisode assez tragique
c'est qu'à un moment vous vous dites que
vous avez une assurance vie et pour que
votre femme puisse toucher cette
assurance vie peut-être vous allez vous
suicider quoi un matin en allant au
travail et donc sur la nationale 10
je me suis dit j'ai prié j'ai
mon père
ouais et puis
disons ma voiture a broutée
j'ai heurté le milieu du terre-plein
central et ça s'est arrêté et puis là
j'ai comme une présence divine en
quelque sorte qui a dit mais tu fais des
conneries descends arrête-toi donc j'ai
tremblé pendant
une demi-heure donc incapable de
remonter dans la voiture et
puis j'ai dit non
c'est vrai j'ai une épouse adorable j'ai
des enfants
un jour il y a un huissier chez vous et
puis elle vous la voyez plus vous vous
avez un pressentiment
vous prenez votre voiture et vous la
retrouvez au bord de la Nationale debout
comme ça et prête à se jeter sous le
premier poids lourd qui qui passe quoi
je la prends dans mes bras tu m'as
pardonné on va reconstruire on va
recommencer nos enfants seront là il
revenaient des DOM-TOM donc ma fille
avait signé un contrat de 4 ans nous les
avions en vacances et puis on a dit on
va on va démarrer aujourd'hui vous vivez
chez votre fille avec 600 euros par mois
c'est vrai que la vie que vous aviez
dans les années 90 c'est un lointain
souvenir quoi ça fait ça fait très mal
comment on fait pour vous acheter des
vêtements pour manger des vêtements j'en
achète pas
de toute façon où on va dans des
dans les farfouilles et puis les
restaurants c'est fini le coiffeur c'est
fini
tu vas sauver la nourriture ça coûte
cher la viande
psychologiquement comment ça va
disons que ça va mieux et votre femme
comment ça va ma femme elle est toujours
sous traitement donc c'est un
hospitalisé votre femme souvent en 2000
entre 2000 si c'est 2007 10
hospitalisations la même année et nous
n'avions pas le tiers payant nous
devions faire l'avance de de soins
radiologiques et autres de et ça c'était
très dur et quand vous demandez une aide
quelconque qu'on vous la refoule en
disant monsieur votre petit chien jouait
pas le soigner mettez le spa si vous
pouvez pas mettre de l'essence dans
votre voiture marcher à pied alors qu'on
est à 20 km des commerces Georges si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil vous avez fait des
conneries quand même la connerie déjà
c'est que je ne ferai pas confiance à
mon employeur pour avoir des choses
deuxième chose toute façon surtout c'est
d'en parler assez proche de se confier
bon là il faut une certaine dose
c'est aussi de voir le centre des impôts
parce qu'il y a pas que des gens qui
vont vous jeter on peut discuter et dire
voilà ce qui m'arrive plutôt que
d'emprunter 21% vous voyez si vous
pouvez pas me faire sauter une partie de
mes impôts ou éventuellement des annuler
puis au moins simplement et puis
aussi c'est de déposer un dossier de
surendettement beaucoup plus rapidement
finalement
c'est terrible parce que toute votre vie
vous avez travaillé vous avez bien
réussi je suis parti de rien j'arrive
avec rien et c'est vraiment l'avantage
et déjà 11 ans de ma retraite c'est de
vraiment de la connerie de dire on n'est
pas en place ce fichier positif s'il
avait été mis en place
on m'aurait bloqué au quatrième ou au
cinquième crédit mais pas au 24e en
France il y a pas de fichiers
normalement il y en aurez beaucoup de
pays où c'est le fichier des incidents
de paiement voilà je suis resté 8 ans
sans incident ouais il y a pas de
fichiers surendettement en France comme
ma propre banque moque 3 2 crédits
supplémentaires alors qu'il y en a déjà
22 qui passe ne croyez pas que c'est un
banquier responsable ça alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire Vincent payant la crise
économique et financière dont on nous
rabat les oreilles c'est les suprêmes
c'est déjà les crédits nous sommes dans
un monde dans lequel il y a des gens qui
considèrent qu'ils peuvent faire de
l'argent sur la misère des autres et on
arrive 21%. faut voir dans quelle
situation plus les gens sont déshérités
plus ils sont faciles à atteindre quand
j'étais député dans la Somme dans une
circonscription très difficile j'avais
d'innombrables locats comme ça ça va de
gens qui sont déjà dans la misère qui
ont vend des encyclopédies à des
milliers d'euros on n'ose pas le dire au
mari au brutalisme même les gens seuls
chez eux en situation de banc et
derrière les banques telles qui
d'ailleurs font à nouveau des profits
considérables donc il faut un rapport de
force avec les banques beaucoup plus
dures et pour un homme ou une femme
politique dire les crédits revolving
vous savez vous allez au supermarché
avec ça on va les interdire et puis ça
ne se fait jamais oui il faut les choses
à faire là-dessus les interdits moi j'ai
caoutchi ouais moi je préfère pas dire
ce que je pense des banques parce que
j'aurais des problèmes mais moi je suis
pour le fichier positif moi je cache pas
que je pense qu'il faut un contrôle
beaucoup plus ferme avec une notion
simple la bonne foi quand on est de
bonne foi on n'a pas affilié du fric aux
institutions financières qui sont du
fric sur ce dos là c'est inadmissible
Jean-Charles hameau ce qui est troublant
dans votre cas c'est que vous avez vous
avez connu un certain moment la belle
vie votre situation il y a des tas de
gens qui la vivent parce qu'ils n'ont
pas vécu la belle vie c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont pris des crédits pour essayer
de vivre avec une vie d'utopie face à la
société de consommation en se disant si
je prends des crédits je pourrais
m'offrir cette télé cet écran plasma je
pourrais m'offrir cette voiture je
pourrais offrir des vacances parce que
maintenant c'est les vacances qu'on peut
acheter à crédit à mes fils et tout donc
en tout cas le crédit c'est quelque
chose qui est hyper
fragile hyper dangereux c'est une je le
lirai à l'utopie on a vu ce qu'il a fait
aux États-Unis récemment et ça c'est
gravissime bien merci de votre
témoignage Georges et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu